ayer tuve la oportunidad de conocer a
una de las personas que trabajan en el
taller y me sé lo comprometidos
dedicados y talentosos que son los
equipos
es imposible mirar una conexión sin
pensar en los cientos de horas de
trabajo que se han invertido en ella
espero que la alta costura dure para
siempre porque me una competencia es
como ninguna otra
[Música]
para la alta costura de este verano 2022
a causa de la pandemia solo 17 marcas es
decir un poco más de la mitad de las
casas presentes en el calendario oficial
desfilaron en la vida real es importante
que nos reunamos lo primero que llama la
atención con tierra son los bordados
gigantes creados por dos brillantes
artistas indios una decoración acorde
con toda la colección
el punto de partida de esta colección
fue celebrar el bordado
porque a veces tenemos la idea de que el
bordado es solo un adorno
qué es un alarde que además es caro en
sí lo bate reality
pero en realidad el bordado habla de
elementos culturales
de identidades porque algunos elementos
forman parte de la tradición
muy a menudo son empresas familiares que
la madre o el padre transmiten al
hermano oa la hija
de su finca de actividades tanto así que
creo que hay que apreciar los valores de
conocimientos que hay detrás del bordado
porque la crisis de cobre puede
desencadenar una catástrofe mundial
es muy posible que estas habilidades
desaparezcan
si no hay una marca de alta costura que
las mantenga vivas
perpetuar una herencia es también lo que
motiva a champions cualquier desde que
se retiró algo rienda suelta a los
diseñadores a los que invita a
apropiarse de su universo después de la
japonesa chicos ave es el diseñador
belga klein martins quien han recibido
las llaves de sus talleres por una
temporada
me ha encantado la colección es creo que
se realmente yo es una extensión de
listos siento que me he hecho un lifting
está muy bien como todos mis códigos
pero los hizo de manera formidable
entiendo hacia donde yo iba pero
realmente llegando más lejos sin embargo
no pensé que llegaría tan lejos porque
creo que verdaderamente tengo muy lejos
que realmente su cultura es un diseño
muy hermoso y siento mucha admiración y
felicidad todo todo todo incluso es un
tratamiento de los materiales los temas
que me gustan los rallys él era
coordinador lo hizo allí pero a lo loco
por todos nadie yo solo me atreví a
hacer la parte de atrás totalmente
acordonado hacia arriba
pero él hizo el frente la espalda las
mangas y la cola y todo todo todo estaba
allí quiero decir es una exageración
pero es muy hermoso es magnífico y al
mismo tiempo poético y todo no es muy
hermoso es muy limpio y muy bueno estoy
encantado
y encontrar soluciones para seguir
existiendo contra viento y marea y
encontrar el deseo para querer provocar
nuevos deseos a pesar de las
dificultades para abastecerse de
materias primas o de las retiradas de
última hora de los modelos enfermos de
kobe alexandre vauthier sigue siendo un
ferviente creyente del paso medio lleno
tenemos que demostrar que las cosas van
a cambiar y tenemos que darle el gusto a
la gente por volver a hacer las cosas
creo que debemos afrontar los próximos
meses con verdadero optimismo pensando y
esperando que las cosas vuelven a
avanzar hacia la cohesión social hacia
la belleza hacia la feminidad y el
diseño es para mí una forma ilimitada de
hacer llegar este mensaje quería dar una
bofetada o un puñetazo o una especie de
llamada de atención y con las chicas
felices me alegré de ver a las chicas
emocionadas como antes del hobbit en los
camerinos
después de un momento difícil siempre
hay una explosión de energía y un deseo
de liberación si miras los locos años 20
fue divertido en extremo así que ya sea
en parís londres berlín bueno fue
realmente uno
así que volví a los años 20 que es un
período un poco postraumático y pensé sí
eso es no quiero las mismas siluetas que
no he hecho desde un punto de vista
técnico nunca ensayo el 10 voy a apostar
por estas siluetas excesivamente largas
elegantes con mucho movimiento y en
trabajado en ellos puse a los bordadores
a los fabricantes de plumas a los
proveedores de telas hasta los zapatos
bordados que llegaron 10 minutos antes
del lobbista 10 minutos antes del
espectáculo bueno la locura también es
ya sabes aprendes mucho sobre ti mismo
cuanto más grandes son los retos más se
aprende sobre uno mismo tu resistencia
dónde vas cuando trabajas con 180
proveedores cuando tienes equipos
ocupados y todo eso y eres el centro de
todo tienes que ser muy muy flexible y
es interesante no pensé que pudiera ser
un acróbata en fin me río no en serio me
río
y recuperar el sueño no es fácil pero
como dice el dicho el que no arriesga no
gana
[Música]